big story today chris bassett is back
he's on the mound five weeks after
getting hit in the right side of the
face cheek area by the line drive you
send this man out to the mound
and you give everybody
that much-needed jolt of energy that
much-needed shot in the arm and i've got
chills now just thinking about how
committed chris bassett has been to
getting himself
back in a position to try to help
lead the charge
down the stretch jp crawford leads it
off for the maritals now here's the
wind-up and the 1-0 pitch and that's
swung on and blooped into right center
that's going to get down for a base hit
and up the field that is pender plays it
back and that's the way our ball game
begins bassett in trouble two on and
nobody out now seeger is about to get
216 but 35 homers and 100 rbis
two and two here it is and that is hit
the knees ring him up strike three call
seeger can't believe it 2-2 change-up
after back-to-back breaking balls and
was at the bottom of the zone pretty
good pitch so runners at the corners
with two outs for jared kelnick
the pop-up
matt chapman is there
and he's got it so chris bassett has to
work a little bit in the top of the
first but he gets out of it seattle
mayors you say kikuchi
making his third start this season
against the oakland a's kaibi's pitched
fairly well against haze in those first
two averaging about six innings a little
over seven punch-outs a game here's
marta right-handed hitter bottom of the
first no score
into center and calnet comes in on the
slip and slide and makes the catch for
round number two he's been covering some
ground in this series this looks like
it's going to be a hit plenty of speed
but a really nice break on it two outs
two on
and a scoreless first
going after the first pitch that will
help things out toro back pedals here
comes celtic so you say kikuchi gets out
of a jam here at the bottom of the first
i think if you got three or four innings
from chris bassett i think everybody
would be thrilled two and two the count
to jake fraley
fraley swings and misses second
strikeout for bassett well it looks like
chris bassett's uncle charlie's doing
just fine haven't seen him in a while
either bassett brings him on down to the
party with one out in the bottom of the
second they have runners at first and
third so here's elvis andrews chance for
the ace to grab the lead line drive
centerfield kelnick jumps up makes the
catch
chapman tags chapman's going to come in
to score
so alba sanders with a line drive
sacrifice fly
so these grab an early one-nothing lead
the athletics behind bassett have a
one-nothing lead over the mariners
they've seen cal raleigh the rookie
catcher leading things off
that's the swing in the base raleigh
strikes out third strikeout for passing
it's a good sign as well because that's
three strikeouts
and you got one on the changeup one on
the curveball one on the fastball two
outs nobody on and ty france at the
plate he walked his first time up as
chris bassett tries to close out this
third inning
and a big curveball france swings and
misses good inning
a couple of strikeouts four on the
afternoon for chris bassett so one
nothing bottom of the third chris bass
it looks like he's probably done for the
afternoon after three innings melvin
waiting for him nice job kid so that has
to be a good feeling for chris bassett
not only getting back out there but
doing a good job walking away feeling
good about yourself you're walking away
feeling healthy and you're going to feel
like hey i i i helped my team have a
chance to win today's game which
ultimately is the most important thing
so here's john gomes
driven center field kellneck racing back
this one's going to get over his head
here comes matt olson digging around
third olson's going to
score two nothing eight gomes gets his
52nd rbi still only one out and here's
markana
this one is driven toward left field and
it's going to bounce off of fraley
gomes is going to hustle in he read it
well he's going to score three nothing
the a's leading here's abraham torrell
toro for one his flight out to
martay in center field
polled and fair
seeger is on his way to third
kyle seeger's being waved home here he
comes and kyle seeger scores standing
abraham toro with two outs in the fourth
inning he puts the mariners on the board
a's lead at three to one looking for
more as they send up shaw murphy
first pitch
driven to right center that's it well
and that baby's gone
murphy homers it's four to one who's
hungry it's lunchtime and shawn murphy's
serving up oppo tacos for everybody
number 17 for sean murphy now raleigh's
second time up today looking to get back
on track offensively
crowley with a deep blast out to right
field cal raleigh with a tank
and he brings the mariners within a run
his second home run both against the
athletics
it's a one-run ball game first batter is
mitch haninger annie today has reached
on a fielder's choice and struck out
looking
pitch swung on and drilled deep to right
backing up pinder on the track reaching
up over the fence
and that baby's gone we got a tie ball
game mitch henniger with a home run ties
it up his 35th rbi number 85 and the
mariners keep on battling back and
they've done it again holy smokes that
ball just kept on going an opposite
field shot to right field as pinder
tries to bring it back at the top of the
wall he made a valiant effort but it
just kept right on going luis terrence
he's going to pinch it he bats with the
go ahead run aboard
crushed
this is a rifle shot and go what a
screamer of a home run from luis
terrence he turns on 96 up and in
goodbye home run mariners in front six
for the sixth inning everything the a's
have put out there has for the most part
gone sideways matt chapman the lead off
the bottom of the eighth inning
[Applause]
don't know that you can hit a ball any
harder than that that ball was smoked
we've seen some great defense that's
extraordinary and here's andrews the
tying run up there at home plate elvis
is swinging a line drive to his right at
short j.p crawford makes the catch and
that's going to retire the side two away
and that'll bring up matt olson olson
drives on right field hanniger's back
turns around looking up and that baby's
gone six to five number 38 for matt
olsen we will not go quietly into the
night here is jed lowry
fly ball and this should do it
crawford is out and for the first time
ever the mariners sweep a four-game
series inside the oakland coliseum and
the marital september march keeps on
ticking